[Music]
who's ready to kick off superhero season
wait what guardians of the galaxy -
already came out okay who's ready to
kick off DC superhero season if you're
not the comic book type we've got sci-fi
and fantasy games for you this week -
and don't forget to subscribe to get new
releases delivered to you every Sunday
let's get to it
NetherRealm has quite the recipe with
injustice and the sequel is bringing
even more heroes and villains into the
fold the roster includes classics like
Superman Batman and the Joker Plus
lesser known characters like cheetah and
firestorm you can throw down with 28
different fighters on day one plus the
mastermind Darkseid if you pre-ordered
with even more DLC characters on the way
if the Justice League movie ends up
sucking at least we'll already have in
justice - in our hands after it hits ps4
and Xbox one on Tuesday May 16th with a
PC release coming later and if you want
to see more of the roster right now
we've got character breakdowns for just
about everyone
from Green Arrow to Green Lantern maybe
you prefer to let guns do the talking
for you and in that case you should
check out Farpoint this PlayStation VR
exclusive drops you onto a hostile alien
world and speaking from personal
experience you really do have to move
and duck behind cover when battling your
way to safety that's a it's personal
experience with the game by the way I
haven't actually been to an alien planet
but if I were going to do that I'd want
to bring a friend and Farpoint does
support two-player co-op as well the
optional gun controller peripheral ain't
too shabby either you can get your hands
on all of that on May 16 let's stick
with sci-fi for a bit longer with the
surge which I'm sorry to say has nothing
to do with the worlds radish soda
sir the surge is from the same team
behind lords of the fallen and it covers
its Dark Souls style gameplay with a
coat of sci-fi paint so instead of
wearing armor and swinging rusty weapons
you'll be donning an exosuit with plenty
of modular upgrades at the ready you can
battle all the other cybernetic beasts
on ps4 Xbox one and PC on the 16th and
now let's swap sci-fi for fantasy with
mages of mist Ralia imagine if a Zelda
game let you create all sorts of crazy
spells and you've got the general idea
speaking from experience you can even
make spells powerful enough to take down
bosses in one hit that's a that's
personal experience with the game again
by the way I don't actually study
witchcraft in my spare time
but anyway solving puzzles collecting
treasure and exploring dungeons is a lot
more fun when you can craft just about
any kind of spell you want using a wide
variety of bases and mods you can give
it a whirl on ps4 and PC on Thursday May
19th and how about some fantasy from
Nintendo it hasn't been too long since
we got a Fire Emblem game but shadows of
Valencia is a bit different from the
tactics games you remember it's actually
a remake of the second game in the
series Fire Emblem Gaiden but with more
options to explore the world and
Traverse dangerous dungeons beyond that
it's largely the same tried-and-true
rock-paper-scissors tactical combat we
all love you can take a swing because
like swords get it on 3ds on Friday the
19th and those are the big games we'll
be playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more great games next week
you